when they look for the breadcrumbs they
were gone
eat the [ __ ] duck hi I'm Dave we've I
mean we just we know okay I don't know
your name but welcome to my house I have
people come by to watch cartoons I've
been doing this for about 17 years
it's all lies this cartoon is called
Hansel and Gretel okay story I'm
familiar with okay it's one of my
favorite tales of lore about baking
children that's right
yeah that's right the guy who made this
also made Jason and the Argonauts and
Clash of the Titans the first ones way
back when the one would the Brad Pitt
guy sure I don't know that his mom did
the costumes for this and your mom at
the Casa died a little work on it too
anyways we did the costumes for this
carton mmm
might not be a cartoon I have a feeling
it isn't Jimmy go ahead and roll it
let's let's get right into this one roll
em Jimbo you don't get to see
[Music]
when he [ __ ] doubted me I told you
was talking about you doubted me he was
creating the photos were there a nun
when I said it's Hansel and Gretel you
said [ __ ] and I said that I said I
knew the story and then I asked who Ray
Bradbury was and you [ __ ] your pocket
protector I can't tell if I'm in cartoon
or real world don't worry about it oh no
no we're in this world this sort of stop
animation is like when you sit on your
uncle's lap too long just weird vibe Oh
No now kill the boy don't look at me
don't smile he's happy with that
existence Hansel's been sweeping the rug
like a [ __ ] idiot
yeah he's by the way he's not picking
anything up oh oh oh hand so this is
gonna come back to bite you want to
which burns you go out of boy
no no this is the [ __ ]
is that are we gonna get any words there
if it's right there you little jerk-off
who I I do not like Hansel Gretel is
great though easy pal
you know sometimes I wish I we didn't
have to kill your mother for food but we
didn't remain soup out of her and you
have mom bread he was it was barely
it's hard to read that worried hey you
ever worried that uh Gretel's obsessed
with the window what a lock he dropped
the calm I've been saving that that was
a year of dad you do dad's got it like
man up a little bit he's kind of taking
this harder than anyone who was just
some milk like like like I like how long
are they gonna live that was the last
milk yeah yeah seriously he's like oh no
will die for hours sooner all right go
get food guys children all right watch
them get that ax get that outdoor ax get
the ax
okay well that's bread yes so far you're
working on a net loss of food okay so
they have their only food and they're
gonna use that to lure berries to lure
berries
we're huntin berries okay so you're
[ __ ] idiot so your idea is to get
berries and by doing that you're gonna
leave yourself a path of bread
I tell you what bread on the ground in
the forest does not last long
yeah you've just that that is all that's
gonna get you're just gonna have a full
duck I've [ __ ] loved this duck you
know this is the first time that they're
planned that it stands out how
ridiculously dumb it was yeah not good
well leave a trail of food leave some
more space eat the [ __ ] duck yeah
serious that's I am a man who does not
believe in eating animals in this
situation you eat the duck there's some
goddamn food right in 40-foot stuffed
you [ __ ] why you guys are [ __ ] idiots
getting a real kind of southern vibe
from those two
if I was no [ __ ]
oh no oh I'm the [ __ ] of the tree green
which I don't have
she was blue by the way they said green
well I mean if that's all we're gonna
get him on I've got a longer gripe list
okay okay yeah this is great
cocaine which anyway that's a yeah you
know this is a little bit like the
villain and James Bond it's like look
just kill him can't believe we didn't
see it before
close those mouths yeah let's get some
moisture going in the facial area happy
candy and besides were covered with so
eat it it's the house that'll stop dad
from killing himself doesn't really
rhyme which
oh you poor hungry children the old
woman said in a very cheerful voice but
do you think the mouths just didn't shut
like yeah they're just built open so
they can't uh oh there we go he's into
it so I think he built another head to
put on there for like great moments yeah
he probably had a second head do you
have like a vegetable house or no like a
fruit no meat house yeah what I will
kill you via diabetes today a carb house
no okay so we're gonna eat this and then
just vomit yeah you know what I like to
eat the children to eat the sweets oh I
could just this kid's mouth needs to
stop [ __ ] both of them oh that's a third
mouth that mouth is crazy yes yes
himself up yeah he's good enough should
put him in a cage there crate training
him
hey Gretel step the [ __ ] up Jesus well
how do you just watch that who do you
want an invitation while your brother
gets killed
you can't have a ruse continuing while
you've put one of the two people in a
Cell oh that happens
so might as well help out yeah that's
the other there I don't think we're
gonna need a new mouth for Gretel that's
pretty much the face you stick with push
her in well [ __ ] pleasure and let's
go you what she must do murder an old
woman
she's a murderer she had to but I was so
easy you had to you had doing that so
she's a murderer
you have to do that's the she better
there better be a trial at least today
and starving Hansel and Gretel finally
dated yeah where's your [ __ ] duck
yeah hey brave deed the entire forest
was now free of the witch's evil spell
kill him eat him kill him guys kill the
Robin there there dad is going to kill
himself
kill the rabbit just snap its neck I
don't know they eat it raw that's it
kill the [ __ ] rabbit no you don't
kill him he's leading you to Gold dummy
well okay so he leads you to gold and
then you kill him well you don't need to
kill him then you give some sort of
moral compass that's what you need but
you know what this is gonna have they're
gonna walk into the house with all the
jewels and dad's just hanging from the
ceiling he'd almost given up hope I get
there for 40 minutes yeah yeah well when
do you give up hope that cup of an
afternoon is his new eyebrows can go
[ __ ] themselves his whole face is an
issue it's a page about rabbits rabbits
at this point so hungry would be eating
the rabbit raw [ __ ] story
leave it to the Germans to make up a bad
story with children that is as German
huh
I mean how what else could it be I just
need Belgian or something if it's German
to me it takes on this whole new vibe I
don't like anything about that you don't
know what you're looking at me for
brought you over here to punch it up I
made some work on it hey pal I'm gonna
be honest I'm walking away from the
project what I think it's perfect
I have no notes maybe give the dad one
different mouth oh and let's see the
kiss between the kids that's building up
to this culminating romantic moment
between brother and sister give us what
we need you know we're all sitting here
thinking the same thing
get it on if you're Hansel make the move
you'll see you later have you ever been
around people before no but a lot of
little figurines I spent a lot of time
around those in my workshop you should
come over sometime I got an oven I'd
like to show you a little bit about no
you can sleep in the cage no no no we
have fun I'll pay myself Green no the
whole time
[Music]